communication is about risk taking many
of us are held back by our fears and
concerns about what might happen today
we'll explore having a bias for action
and being Direct in immediate with our
audiences
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
today I am super excited to chat with
Dan pink Dan is the author of five New
York Times bestsellers including his
latest the power of regret how Looking
Backward moves us forward early in his
career Dan served as a political
speechwriter including being Chief
speechwriter to vice president Al Gore
welcome Dan I am so looking forward to
our conversation
Matt it is great to be here a long time
listener first-time guest thank you
there's so many things that I want to
talk about I just want to jump right in
many of our listeners find themselves
preparing presentations and structuring
speeches earlier in your career you
served as a speechwriter and I'm curious
what two or three lessons can you share
for how to prepare and deliver a great
talk well I mean political speech
writing and political speech giving I
think it can be different from giving a
sales presentation or giving a lecture
at a university however I do think that
there are some principles of that realm
that we can extract for other Realms so
one of them would be audience first all
right you got to think about the
audience what do they know
what don't they know what do they care
about what don't they care about and one
of the things that we did if it'll allow
me a small tangent here is back when I
was working for as a chief speech writer
for vice president Al Gore is that when
he went out into America you know
outside of Washington to do things we
would always work massively to find what
we called how the hells okay how the
hells and how the hell would be
something like this it's like he would
get up there and say oh man you know
you're in I'm making this up you're in
Sheboygan Wisconsin it's like ah sorry
I'm a little bit late but I wanted to
have a second cinnamon roll at
McGillicuddy's you know and people with
the reaction to the crowd would be how
the hell does he know about
mcgillicuddies everybody in Sheboygan
knows about McGillicuddy's so but the
idea of say thinking of the audience
first I think is a really important
principle another one would be which I'm
violating right now is say less there
has never been a speech certainly a
political speech where people at the end
of it said gosh I wish he or she would
have talked longer say alas I remember
one time saying a lot of times he's in
the White House these speeches circulate
and so there was a speech not ours that
was circulating and it was a draft of a
speech it was Clinton's speech where the
draft of the speech literally said and
my plan has 14 pillars and I'm like this
is this is not going to stand up with 14
pillars that's about 11 pillars too many
all right and then the final one is
especially for political speeches but I
think it's true for you know other other
Realms is that ultimately you have to
think about the purpose the purpose of
the speech is to Galvanize action it's
not to show how smart you are it's not
to sort of give your own Wizardry about
your Mastery of a topic especially in
political speeches you want them to do
something you want them to go and vote
you want them to go paid for a higher
minimum wage you want them to try to
stop the other side from doing X Y or Z
and so when you think about these things
audience first say less and ultimately
you want the audience to act I think
those are helpful lessons for any
communicator
absolutely they are and they have been
echoed in many different ways across
this podcast but having a clear goal
knowing what it is you want being very
concise and connecting your content in a
way that's relevant and meaningful and I
love the how to Hell point and I think
that's that's a great thing for people
to think about it's it a little specific
details that demonstrate you've spent
time thinking about and appreciating who
you're speaking to can go a long way I I
really appreciate that well I I mean
this mostly in in the realm of corporate
communication which which includes
speech giving but includes sort of the
way in many ways the ways that companies
interact with their their employees and
interact with their customers to me the
embodiment of how to do it wrong is the
phrase we apologize for any
inconvenience this might have caused you
now that phrase which all of us have
seen has been said by faceless
corporations but has never been said by
a human being human beings don't talk
that way you and I happen to be
conversing right now via the magic of
the internet we are not in the same
physical space but suppose that we were
in the same physical space we were in
the same studio and I am a clumsy guy I
guarantee I will knock over the
microphone at some point during this
conversation so let's say you and I were
together and I had a cup of coffee and
because I talk with my hands because I'm
clumsy maybe I'd spill the cup I spill
coffee on you right you're wearing a
nice gray sweater I spill my dark black
coffee on your beautiful gray sweater
what would I say under those
circumstances I would not say oh Matt
I'm sorry for any inconvenience this
might have caused you what would you I
would say oh my God Matt I'm so sorry I
can't believe I did that I'm so sorry
what can I do to to make it right and so
I think that the more we just forget the
performative side of saying oh this is
how official language is this is how
companies talk this is how a smart
person is supposed to talk and we just
talk like we talk I actually really
think that it's it's more compelling you
know and what you're doing especially
with let's go back to speeches or and I
think a lot of written communication as
well what you're trying to do is you're
not trying to sound like somebody else
you're trying simply to sound like a
better version of yourself
that's the key you know and and we can
go back like I was I was in college I
was a Linguistics major so if you so so
and one of the few things that you learn
in linguistics is the ability to go very
meta very quickly and I can go very meta
very quickly on you if when we think
about think about this just in terms of
the human species human beings have been
conversing as you and I are human beings
have been conversing for its you know
200 000 years right it is not anything
we learned we didn't learn how to
converse it is who we are it's part of
our Evolution as a species and we've
been doing it for 200 000 years we have
been writing
you know written communication for only
five thousand years like a fraction of
that time written communication is in is
an invention it is not something we do
naturally and so and and then if you
think about the distribution of written
information the printing press That's
only 500 years-ish old and so this so so
you know we're learning how to do this
kind of written communication this
formal communication and for whatever
weird reason we have diverged from what
we already do as an evolutionary ability
and so the more you can I guess so let's
let's be practical here the goal has to
be
to sound like a better version of
yourself not to sound official not to
sound like somebody else but to sound
like a slightly more organized more
coherent version of yourself
clearly when we communicate we want to
avoid
distancing ourselves from the people
we're talking about you know in in my
field we talk a lot of what you said
resonates in is captured by this idea of
immediacy you want to connect and you
want to be immediate and you use
language that is inviting to people I
recently coached a very senior leader at
a tech company and he was giving a
presentation for three thousand five
thousand people and he started by saying
knowledge workers must
and I stopped him I said who's in the
audience he said knowledge workers and I
said so why don't you just say you all
right I mean we need to communicate and
use language that that invites people in
and doesn't distance ourselves I do
think many of us think that to sound
smarter we have to use big words and
formal exactly ways of speaking and what
I'm hearing you say is being a better
version of yourself is not using big
words it's just connecting and really
thinking about your point and how it can
resonate is that right yes being a
clearer version of yourself not having
this kind of Fantastical notion of What
official speak is or what smart speak is
and the thing is it's like we have in
our brains literally the programming
that allows us to do that that it like
to me it takes more cognitive effort for
a company to come up with this
ridiculous we're sorry for any
inconveniences might have caused you
rather than saying oh my God we're so
sorry we messed up absolutely I love the
Mantra speak like a human and I think
all of us can take the time to practice
and run our our Communications by other
people and and have as as the first
threshold did it make sense and does it
sound conversational in your writing and
speaking you've studied a lot about
persuasion and selling you talk about
focusing on problem finding not problem
solving can you define these two
concepts and explain how to leverage
problem finding in being persuasive in
selling so problem solving is addressing
a clearly stated issue that already
exists and likely has a solution problem
finding is actually surfacing that when
people don't know that it exists right
now why is one now more important than
the other this is a big deal because
problem solving is becoming a commodity
and this is particularly true this is
true throughout White Collar work but
it's particularly true in sales if I am
in the market for I'm looking around my
office here if I'm in the uh if I'm in
the market for a vacuum cleaner and and
oh my God my floor is dirty I I need a
vacuum cleaner and you're a vacuum
cleaner sales person
I really need you very much I know what
I need I need a vacuum cleaner I can go
online I can find the best price I can I
can find the best model for that for
that vacuum cleaner you're not very
useful to me I don't need you right your
ability to solve that problem get down a
vacuum cleaner is meaningless however
where are you more useful you're more
useful if
that's not actually my problem if I'm
wrong about my problem and so maybe the
problem is that I have crappy screens on
my windows here and all this kind of
Gunk is getting in here and it doesn't
matter whether I have a vacuum cleaner
so if you can sort of surface a problem
that I don't realize that I have that is
more difficult to commodify and
therefore there's a greater premium on
problem finding rather than on problem
solving I love this notion of
really flipping the script it's not
about giving the solution it's about
finding what's the right problem and it
gets back to something you said earlier
about really knowing your audience and
understanding their needs can help you
find the problems that can be beneficial
to them well that's a huge question and
I'll have to offer at the start Madame
mayor culpa because in that book I don't
think I really got purpose quite right I
think about it differently now than when
I wrote that book no refunds for anybody
but I still think about it differently
it's still value there's still value
yeah yeah and so so so what we think of
as purpose particularly when it comes to
on the job is that I'm going to be more
motivated to do something if my job is
connected to something larger than
myself so not only am I filing this
report or doing this audit but I'm doing
it in the service of stopping the
climate crisis and we have a lot of good
evidence in organizational behavior that
that is absolutely a performance
enhancer if you go to say University
fundraisers and show them la letters
from people who were on the receiving
end of the money that they were raised
or have them meet people who benefited
from the money that they raise they
raise more money so purpose is an
inherent performance enhancer but
there's also a quieter kind of purpose
where you're not only making a
difference you're just making a
contribution we can think of one as
capital P purpose my work is solving the
climate crisis I'm feeding the hunger
but there's another one where you're
just making a contribution there's a
great study out of Harvard Business
School showing that in a cafeteria when
they rigged up an iPad that allowed the
cooks to see the customers the quality
of the food improved and what that meant
was that the cooks were not getting paid
more the cooks were not feeding the
unhoused the cook simply saw the purpose
of what they were doing they were making
a contribution so when we think of it
capital P purpose am I making a
difference in the world small P purpose
am I just making a contribution I'm
cooking a cheese omelette and someone's
going to eat it I'm gonna up my cheese
omelette game a bit my colleague is
having difficulty getting a report out
the door I'm going to help her do that
it's not going to change the world but
it's a a contribution to another human
being I'm in a call center and somebody
calls in and they have this problem with
their headphones aren't working properly
and I'm going to solve their problem I'm
not changing the world in any way but
I'm making a contribution and what we
see it's really exciting is that a lot
of times especially in leadership we're
over indexed on how leaders always tell
people how to do stuff they don't
explain enough about why people are
doing is important why it matters why it
connects to making a contribution or
making a difference and as gooey as that
sounds I think there's almost
incontrovertible evidence that why that
sense of purpose is the most cost
effective performance enhancer that
organizations have it's really a
catalyst right by helping people
understand why they're doing what
they're doing and and it's predicated of
course on leadership understanding what
their mission and vision is and then
helping people understand how they play
in that but that's a great way to
enhance the performance you're looking
for and it goes to what we're talking
about before which is the importance of
the basis of a lot of what you've been
working on for all these years which is
the importance of conversation and that
management leadership is not about
dictation it's it's not about one-way
Direction it's about a conversation and
a conversation to a list of the very
best from people includes instruction
and guidance on how to do things but it
also surfaces why people are doing
things why what they do matters why it
connects to something else
and by empowering people with the why
you can motivate the behavior that
you're seeking many of those listening
get very anxious and nervous about their
communication be it presenting making
small talks speaking up in a meeting
asking somebody out on a date in your
newest book The Power of regret you
discuss the role of risk as it relates
to regret can you talk about how our
perceived risk often does not match the
actual risk and the implications that it
might have for our motivations and our
anxieties and and maybe even
specifically to communication this is I
think a big takeaway from that from that
book in that book I looked at uh this
this misunderstood emotion of regret and
among the things that I did is I
collected regrets now we have about 25
000 regrets from around the world and I
also did a big survey of the U.S
population about their attitudes on
regret and one of the things that you
see let's go start with the the U.S
public opinion survey we did this very
large sample to try to find demographic
differences in what people regret how
they regret it so forth so we over Sam
in every demographic category we spent a
lot of money to try to find these
demographic differences and there
weren't that many but there was one big
one that goes directly to your point
which is this
in the architecture of regret you can
have regrets about action and inaction
regards about what you did in regards
about what you didn't do people in their
20s had about equal numbers of action
and inaction regrets but as people age
really just almost like into the 30s but
certainly 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s the
inaction regrets took over there's about
a three to one two to one three to one
ratio of regrets of inaction over action
what people regret over time are things
they didn't do they didn't take that
trip they didn't ask that person out on
a date they didn't start that business
and I think it's because we are just a
slightly over indexed on risk we
overstate the risk in many circumstances
now this is not a lesson to take risks
all the time you want to take smart risk
but I feel like we need to adjust the
dial one or two clicks and this is
particularly true when it comes to
communication in the what I call the
world regret survey where collected
regrets from all over the world one of
the big category worries of regrets were
What I Call Connection regrets where you
have a friend or someone you care about
deeply but maybe you haven't talked to
them for 10 years and you want to reach
out but it feels really awkward and you
think they're not going to care so you
don't that is a colossal mistake because
it's a colossal forecasting error
because what happens is that when you do
Reach Out
it's way less awkward than people think
to your point or over assessing the risk
second the other side almost always
welcomes the Overture they don't think
it's weird and so and so I do think that
there is some pretty good evidence and
we look at regret and what people regret
over time to have that bias for Action
to speak up to reach out to that friend
to ask somebody out on a date to sort of
be a little bit more risk prone than we
might naturally be because over time
what you're going to regret is not doing
that stuff so first Dan you could have
collected all of those regrets just by
talking to me I've got about 25 000 my
myself so I I could have saved you time
I really see in my own work and in the
work of others that I know who help
people feel more confident speaking that
virtually everybody after the fact after
they've taken that risk say it wasn't as
bad as I thought and the rewards far
outweighed my concerns so I I just
wanted to Echo what you said there and
yet we are often burdened by our fear of
that risk so that we end up ultimately
regretting what could have been and I
hope everybody takes a moment to think
of an upcoming situation where you might
be hesitant because you're afraid of the
risk and take it from Dan pink go do it
it is worth it in terms of your
communication I think there's an
important lesson here it's like just
have that slight bias for Action you
know Nick Eppley has researched about no
one thinks that talking to strangers on
a train they think that if you say if
you go up to somebody on a train are
they going to welcome the Overture and
the view is like no way they're gonna
hate it I'm gonna hate it it's gonna be
totally awkward and that when he did
research in the Chicago public
transportation system he found that the
people who are on the end of the
Overture said oh that was kind of
interesting conversation I'm glad the
person reached out the person who was
instructed to do that said oh that was
way less awkward than we think so bottom
line here is just have a slight bias for
Action I I have found in this regret
research especially this emotion of
awkwardness is a paper tiger push
through that feeling of awkwardness in
any dimension of your life and as you're
saying from the people who you've worked
with when you get to the other side of
that you're typically going to be fine
absolutely and awkwardness is a big
impediment to communication and if we
just try it we often find it's not as
bad as we thought in your book when the
scientific secrets of perfect timing you
give a lot of advice on how to maximize
our motivation and take care of
ourselves in this incredibly fast-paced
always-on world that we live what are
two bits of advice you might have for us
for how to thrive and sustain ourselves
well I guess the first one would be once
again the like research base we have
some pretty good evidence that our
cognitive abilities do not remain
constant over the course of the day they
change they change in material ways and
so being conscious and intentional about
doing the right kind of work at the
right time of day can make a huge huge
difference and unfortunately we're often
very intentional about what we do we're
intentional about how we do it and who
we do it with but when it comes to when
we do stuff we're not intentional and we
should be because it actually matters
the second thing that I would say is
take more breaks I initially in that
book on timing I was going to write
about maybe two pages on breaks in the
chapter on this hidden pattern of the
day and there was so much research and
so good research that I ended up writing
an entire chapter on breaks and what we
should be doing it's a reframing of
sorts we should be thinking of breaks
differently we should be thinking of
breaks as part of our performance not as
a deviation from our performance we have
been sold a bill of goods by the
Puritans who said that the only way to
get more work done and better work done
is to power through and that when you
power through that's also morally
virtuous that's complete nonsense what
we know from many domains is that
professionals take breaks it's not let
amateurs take breaks and professionals
don't it's the exact opposite
professionals take breaks amateurs don't
take breaks so be intentional about your
brakes and where you can the best kinds
of brakes are when you're in motion when
you're outside when you're detached from
your phone or even from your work and
often when you're with somebody else so
even taking like a 15-minute walk break
every afternoon own can be powerfully
helpful in sustaining your intellectual
and physical energy I think taking a
break in conversation and in the work we
do very very important and and this
notion of timing of when things work
best for you is really powerful we've
had Baba shiv who is one of our faculty
here at Stanford's business school who
has studied this and it's fascinating
that we are more collaborative and
creative at certain times of the day and
it's better to try to harness the the
type of activity we do that fits with
those rhythms and absolutely taking
breaks taking time to disconnect can be
really really powerful so Dan before we
end I'd like to ask you the same three
questions I ask everyone who joins me
and I am really curious and excited to
hear your answers are you up for these
yes question one if you were to capture
the best communication advice you ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be decide the promise you're making then
deliver okay okay and then I'll unpack
that very quickly so years ago I was
working on back in the old days when
there were magazines I wrote a lot for
magazines and you know I'd write these
fairly long feature stories four
thousand five thousand words and at one
point you know I was stuck on something
I submitted a draft it was terrible and
I was really stuck and my editor said to
me it's like okay I know the problem
here you don't know what promise you're
making to the reader what promise are
you making to the reader in this piece
and I was like what and that was really
enlightening to me so you so I think
that I think hard about that and when
I'm writing when I'm talking is like
what's the promise am I making to the
reader or The Listener and am I
fulfilling that promise so I decide the
promise you're making then deliver I
think that is really powerful know your
goal know your intention and then act on
it very good
you know so many people and you've had
such a fascinating life question number
two asks who is a communicator that you
admire and why
okay so I think my choice is not
somebody I know not only is it not
somebody I know
but it's not somebody who's alive and
it's somebody who might not be a
somebody it might be somebody's no Jack
I was thinking about this during my walk
I took a walk right after lunch and
before I did this talk with you and I
was thinking ESOP when you think about
it ESOP had these
Parables these fables they were probably
150 words long
they have withstood the test of time to
put it mildly and you know and they
operate they they've lodged in our
brains so powerfully that you can use
phrases like
tortoise in the hair
or sour grapes or you know ant in the
Grasshopper And it sticks and that's
pretty good so I'm going to vote for
ESOP you have truly gone old school you
are you you have brought up the oldest
suggested great communicator and you
clearly have highlighted some things
that are important for good
communicators something that's memorable
being concise creating something that
has the impact
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
number one
Simplicity number two
brevity see what you did there and I'm
not even going to use my third I know I
saw that Simplicity and brevity make it
accessible make it understandable make
it memorable all very powerful bits of
advice and guidance and Dan everything
you've shared with us has been powerful
it has been such a pleasure to chat with
you thanks the the notion of Being Human
and connecting with humans knowing our
purpose and really understanding our
promise and having a bias for Action all
of these are really powerful thank you
so much I wish you well on your new book
The Power of regret and I appreciate
your time
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn